i don't care that you don't care just
hear what i'm saying okay
we're gonna go we're gonna go well then
good megan then you can be how you
always are
we'll be able to be how you always are
yeah everyone
did need a little time after this hot
topic debate
so i apologize i apologize to you on
thursday
as it often does at the daytime talk
show the tension escalated quickly as
the round table discussion turned to
politics
i told president putin that we need to
have some basic rules of the road
that we can all abide by megan mccain
took aim at president biden's summit
with vladimir putin this week calling
out the president for
this awkward moment with a cnn reporter
which was quickly followed by an apology
from biden
so how does that account to a
constructive meeting as
president president putin you don't
understand that you're in your own
business i owe my last question an
apology
i shouldn't i shouldn't have been such a
wise guy the last
answer i gave in the aftermath of the
incident megan said that overall the
president's actions were downplayed
and she claimed there would have been
more outrage had this come from
former president trump i think i would
just like a little intellectual
consistency if trump had done that
we would be screaming at the top of our
lungs in in one way or another
and i just think that i have heard uh
many people in this town in dc talking
that the press is getting sick of this
and then spouting off at her in a way
that i found
not only um unbecoming and ridiculous
but to do it in a foreign country in
that kind of form particularly bizarre
and just because biden has gotten a pass
so far which he has and continues to do
it is in no one's best interest to treat
him like it's state tv
and that's when whoopi entered the chat
the thing that i never saw
trump do was apologize to anybody and i
will take it when you
you know because sometimes i'm rude to
somebody
i don't i just want to let me just
finish what i'm saying
i don't care if he's apologizing he just
embarrassed him i don't care that you
don't care
just hear what i'm saying we're gonna go
well then good megan then you can be how
you always
are we'll be you can be how you always
are but
coolermine seemingly prevailed over the
commercial break
with both hosts taking a moment to
express regret over their behavior
hey welcome back before we go into
talking to sonny
i want to apologize because i was rude
i didn't need to say what i said and i i
apologize
because that's not the way i want to
behave at work so i apologize
i apologize to you call
in 2019 megan gave e.t her take as to
why so many political arguments come her
way
on the long-running series i try and
just remind myself that i'm representing
50 of the country i'm representing a
bunch of women even though i only have
one chair
and it's really important i also try and
think of as cheesy as it sounds
um what elizabeth hasselbeck used to
mean to me when i was young because i
used to watch the view in college
and she was really such an icon for
young republican women and
i hope i'm giving that to anyone that's
watching and i know there's like you
know
i know because i was just in wyoming i
know there's like people in the middle
of the country that feel like
they're really happy that someone's
representing them